CARLSON TONIGHT" COMING UP NEXT.
HAVE A GOOD NIGHT.
♪ ♪
>> Martha: GOOD EVENING,
WELCOME TO "TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT."
WE WANT TO BEGIN TONIGHT'S SHOW
WITH AN APOLOGY, APOLOGIES ARE
NOT SOMETHING YOU WANT TO HEAR
ON CABLE NEWS ON THIS OR ANY
OTHER SHOW.
BUT WE ARE OFFERING ONE ANYWAY.
THERE IS NO LAWSUIT FORCING US
TO DO IT AND NO COURT -- ORDER
MAKING US ARE SKITTISH
ADVERTISERS.
SINCE HERE IN THIS.
IT HAS TO DO WITH JOE BIDEN.
JOE BIDEN TO RUN FOR PRESIDENT
AGAIN AND BACK IN THE NEWS THIS
WEEK IN ALL THE WRONG WAYS AFTER
A SERIES OF WOMEN ACCUSED HIM OF
INAPPROPRIATE CONTACT.
BIDEN'S FIRST ACCUSER LUCY
DESCRIBED WHAT IT WAS LIKE TO
HAVE THE VICE PRESIDENT HIT THE
TOP OF HER HEAD TO.
>> I FELT HIM GET CLOSER.
HE LEANED IN AND IT WAS LIKE
RIGHT BEHIND ME ALL MY BODY.
AND HE LEANED DOWN, SMELLS MY
HAIR, AND THIN PLANTS THIS BIG,
LONG KISS ON THE TOP OF MY HEAD.
>> Martha: ANOTHER ACCUSER A
WOMAN, REMEMBERS THAT BIDEN GAVE
HER AN UNWELCOME ESKIMO KISS.
>> HE WALKED UP TO ME AND
WRAPPED HIS HANDS AROUND MY FACE
LIKE THAT AND PULLED ME IN AND
STARTED RUBBING NOSES WITH ME.
IT WAS FOR LIKE A GOOD 15
SECONDS.
I REMEMBER THINKING, IS HE GOING
TO KISS ME?
>> YESTERDAY TO WOMEN, AND ONCE
HUGGED HER, A LITTLE TOO
LONG.
AND THIS IS HOW PRESIDENTIAL
CAMPAIGNS DIED.
SO DESPERATE TO END THE STORY,
JOE BIDEN RELEASED A STATEMENT
TODAY, PROMISING NOT TO TOUCH
STRANGERS ANYMORE.
>> IN MY CAREER, I'VE ALWAYS
TRIED TO MAKE A CONNECTION.
THAT IS MY RESPONSIBILITY COME I
THINK MY SHAKE HANDS AND HELP
PEOPLE.
I GRAB MEN AND WOMEN BY THE
SHOULDERS AND TELL THEM YOU CAN
DO THIS.
NOW IT'S ABOUT TAKING SELFIES
TOGETHER.
SOCIAL ORDERS HAVE BEGAN TO
CHANGE AND SHIFT AND THE
BOUNDARIES OF PROTECTING
PERSONAL SPACE HAVE BEEN RESET.
AND I GET IT.
I GET IT.
I HEAR WHAT THEY ARE SAYING.
I UNDERSTAND IT.
AND I WILL BE MUCH MORE MINDFUL.
THAT IS MY RESPONSIBILITY.
THAT IS MY RESPONSIBILITY AND I
WILL MEET IT.
BUT QUITE FRANKLY, LIFE FOR THAT
MATTER IS ABOUT CONNECTING,
ABOUT CONNECTING WITH PEOPLE.
THAT WILL CHANGE.
I WILL BE MORE MINDFUL OF
PEOPLE'S PERSONAL SPACE.
AND THAT IS A GOOD THING.
>> Tucker: THERE IS SOMETHING
SAD, PATHETICALLY ABOUT WATCHING
A 76-YEAR-OLD MAN APOLOGIZING
FOR NOT UNDERSTANDING SELFIE
CULTURE.
YOU HOPE YOUR OWN GOLDEN YEARS
WOULD BE MORE DIGNIFIED THAN
THAT.
BUT THE POLITICIANS, NO CHOICE,
THEY DROVE HIM TO IT.
AND SO DID WE.
THAT IS THE POINT OF THE
APOLOGY.
WHEN THE STORY FIRST ROPE,
PASSING OUT ESKIMO KISSES AND
SNIFFING OTHER PEOPLE'S HAIR IT
WAS IRRESISTIBLE AND YOU COULD
NOT LAUGH AT IT.
AND WE DID.
WE MOCKED JOE BIDEN AS IMPULSIVE
HUGGER, A CUTLER RUN AMOK AND IT
WAS TOO AMUSING.
WHAT WE SHOULD HAVE SAID EVERY
BIT AS LOUDLY AND APOLOGIZE FOR
NOT SAYING IS THAT HUGGING IS
NOT SEXUAL ASSAULT.
ESKIMO KISSES ARE NOT RATE.
THEY USED TO BE OBVIOUS BUT IT'S
NOT OBVIOUS ANYMORE.
AND SO WE ARE SORRY FOR BLURRING
THE DISTINCTION BETWEEN HUMAN
AFFECTION AND OF COURSE IMMORAL
BEHAVIOR.
LAST THING THIS COUNTRY NEEDS IS
MORE PEOPLE THAT THINK THEY ARE
ASSAULTED BECAUSE SENIOR CITIZEN
HUGS THEM WRONG.
SO WE APOLOGIZE FOR ADDING TO
THAT NONSENSE THAT ANTIHUMAN
HYSTERIA.
NONE OF THIS, BY THE WAY,
JOE BIDEN FOR A MAN WERE RUNNING
FOR PRESIDENT WE DISAGREE ON A
LOT OF THINGS.
JUST A WEEK AGO HIS SERB CLEAN
AMERICA TO GET RID OF ENGLISH
TRADITION.
BIDEN SAYS THINGS LIKE THAT ALL
THE TIME AND WE WILL KEEP
CRITICIZING HIM WHEN HE DOES.
BUT HUGGING PEOPLE IS NOT A SIN,
SORRY, IT'S NOT EVEN IF MANY ON
THE LEFT WOULD LIKE TO
CRIMINALIZE IT.
LISTEN TO NANCY PELOSI DESCRIBED
THE LESSONS SHE HAS DRAWN BY
WATCHING JOE BIDEN.
>> I DON'T THINK IT IS
DISQUALIFYING BECAUSE I THINK IT
DOES NOT DISQUALIFY THE
INTENTION.
BUT I THINK IT IS ABOUT
COMMUNICATION IN GENERAL, BEYOND
THIS.
I'M A MEMBER OF THE STRAIGHT ARM
CLUB, A STRAIGHT ARM HYPER --
HYPER ---YOU ARE.
YOU HAVE A COLD AND I HAVE A
COLD.
LET'S PRETEND WE ALL HAVE COLDS.
THAT IS THE WORLD NANCY PELOSI
DEMANDS WE LIVE IN.
BUT WHAT KIND OF SOCIETY AS
THAT.
A PLACE WHERE EVERYONE HAS A
COLD.
IT IS A SICK SOCIETY.
IT IS A COLD AND ANTISEPTIC
PLACE, FEARFUL PLACE.
THE SOCIETY WITH SENSORS
WATCHING AND JUDGING EVERY
ACTION.
HE PLAYS ON WAYS TO GET TOO
CLOSE TO OTHER PEOPLE.
A SOCIETY LIKE THAT IS EXUBERANT
AND HUMAN WORTH -- WARMTH TOO
RISKY TO DISPLAY IN PUBLIC.
A JOYLESS PC HELL, NANCY PELOSI
AND SO MANY ON THE LEFT ALREADY
LIVE THERE.
YOU CAN SEE IT ON THEIR FACES,